good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller the ASEP were going to be looking
at today is SCP 60 a object class
Keter special containment procedures the
grow of which contains SCP 60 is
currently contained in a series of
specially constructed green houses at
satellite site sixty six sixty specimens
are to be pruned regularly to keep at a
manageable size personnel are banned
from smoking while within five
kilometres of satellite site sixty six
sixty personnel are to refrain from
bringing lighters matches tasers or any
other tool readily capable of starting a
fire into satellite site sixty six sixty
SCP sixty special ins are to be watered
twice daily and checked weekly for dead
plant matter and saplings that matter
and saplings are to be pruned shredded
and composted properly in the dedicated
facility on site afterwards returned to
SCP 60s containment chamber fragments of
SCP 60 may not be moved off-site for any
reason without explicit written
permission from two or more level 4
personnel in the event of a breach by
SCP 60 alpha personnel are to enter
lockdown mode and activate on-site fire
suppression systems redundant on-site
fire suppression systems have been
installed throughout the site including
water and chemical retardants to be used
in tandem in the event of a containment
breach portable extinguishers are to be
kept available at all times containment
chambers 60 alpha one is a dedicated
circular containment chamber designed to
contain SCP sixty alpha during testing
this chamber is constructed of concrete
with a point two meter thick asbestos
coating with a series of chimneys to
allow for ventilation of heat during
containment the walls are fitted with 24
co2 projectors evenly spaced at
45-degree angles along the walls and
will activate in the presence of
temperatures exceeding 200 degrees
one kilogram of SCP 60 meter is to be
kept within containment chamber sixty
alpha one to be burned in the event of a
breach description SCP sixty is a grove
of seventeen white oak trees Quercus
Alba The Grove is spread across
approximately eight acres in rural
northern eastern Minnesota the house on
the property was demolished during the
construction of satellite site 6660
after being combed by foundation
personnel for information regarding SCP
60 see addendum when burned SCP 61
entity henceforth designated as SCP 60 a
la pista appears to be an animate adult
human skeleton standing approximately
2.3 metres tall and surrounded by bright
white flames SCP 60 L Phoenicia Lee
burns at a temperature of approximately
1,500 degrees two thousand seven hundred
and thirty degrees Fahrenheit and will
attempt to cause as much damage as
possible when active burning as little
as 20 grams of SCP sixty will cause SCP
sixty alpha to appear only one instance
of scp-1651 today SCP sixty alpha is
extremely dangerous having proven to be
hostile and relatively intelligent it
appears to be a single recurring entity
showing a growing familiarity with
satellite site 66 60s layout over the
course of several manifestations when
given the opportunity it will throw its
Bonnie at flammable materials an effort
to cause damage an assault personnel
with a focus on grappling and
strangulation additionally that is
proving capable of running at speeds of
up to 80 km/h 50 miles per hour in short
bursts and leaping approximately five
meters from a running start
due to the extreme temperatures produced
by six the Alpha during the initial
stages of manifestation along with its
physical capabilities it is capable of
causing large uncontrolled fires and
widespread property damage if left
unchecked scp-1651 it becomes active if
SCP sixty alpha is introduced to a high
enough volume of water or other
flame-retardant material over a short
amount of time it will begin to weaken
to the point that it will collapse into
dust collapse will occur suddenly with
little warning SCP 60 alpha will
continue to pose a threat
up until its collapse the volume of
suppressive material required to subdue
osep 60 alpha is markedly less than
would be expected to quench a heat
source of its intensity with volumes of
approximately 500 litres proving
sufficient areas burned by SCP 60 L
Phillippi 60 over the following four to
six weeks only one wave of sapling
growth will follow any given containment
breach said saplings are easily pulled
and should be composted and supplied to
SCP 60 s normal containment chambers
additional information regarding SCP 60
the property containing SCP 60 contained
a burned-out secluded house upon
foundation acquisition
according to civilian sources the houses
previous owner was a Jonathan Corr Hill
who is reported to have been a somewhat
solitary eccentric with a tendency
towards bitterness and nihilism
mr. core Hillel was reported as a
missing person in late 1996 several
months after having suddenly cut off all
ties to family members and friends the
last person to have had contact with
Jonathan Corr Hill was his brother
Christopher by a telephone call
according to his brother Gore Hill had
developed an interest in the study of
Victorian era occultism furthermore he
reported that Jonathan Corr Hill had
seemed normal
up until the phonecall at which point he
told Christopher never to contact him
again later in the year a mail carrier
visited the home to deliver a notice of
foreclosure finding it instead has a
burned-out shell examination showed that
the fire began in the living room in the
general vicinity of the fireplace
it is now assumed that SCP 60 L feh
manifested within the house while Corr
held burned SCP 60 in the fireplace
considering SCP 60 L FFA's nature why
the house was not entirely destroyed
during this alleged manifestation is as
of yet unknown no human remains were
found within the structure Jonathan Corr
Hills whereabouts and whether he is dead
or alive are currently unknown thank you
very much for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye Jimmy don't touch that [ __ ]
projector Jesus nice
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
tiber ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support is greatly
appreciated if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volcan thank you
you